[Music]
it's et's social study a quick look at
what stars are posting online Britney
Spears make silly faces with her
ten-year-old son Jaden in a cute
Instagram video I love that Kim
Kardashian is working hard to reach her
weight-loss goal Don just company Missy
Elliott okay I'm wearing a full sweat
suit so I gotta lose this extra like 7
pounds meanwhile Lea Michele is showing
off her hot bikini body
the actress shared a series of swimsuit
pics during her girl's trip to Hawaii
and we are living through her vacation
photos it go very very very lucky and
grateful in my life right now moving on
Mariah Carey is another star documenting
her fun getaway with my boyfriend on
Tuesday Mimi arrived in Dubai with her
beau Bryan Tanaka check out the two
lovebirds posing in front of the city's
famous skyscraper before the pop divas
performance we're going to be doing the
Dubai Jazz Festival and and the internet
has found John Legend's animated
doppelganger the Arthur cartoon Chrissy
Teigen tweeted this pic of the character
clenching his fist that read John when
you tell him he looks like Arthur John
responded to his wife's tweet writing I
hadn't even heard of this Arthur
character till now was he around when I
was a kid